Coffee vs. smoothie which one can cure a
hangover better we've created a facility
to test the world's best hangover cures
and we're testing them all I'm dr.
Keller wertham the doctor of internal
medicine
I'm Fran Kranz I'm not a doctor but I've
been hungover a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover that so what
do you guys do I'm a grip and gaffer I'm
a best boy electric and I work with
clothing a lot
tell us about your night I drink a bunch
of IPAs and then chase it all down with
some whiskey got the evidence yeah that
was a character you've had a fair amount
of sugar in that margarita and a lot of
people assume that sugar is what makes
for a worse hangover but actually it's
not the case
fructose in itself speeds up your
metabolism alcohol if you put sugar in
an alcoholic drink you just tend to
drink it faster okay tell us about this
lady ends up making out with her yeah
okay let's talk about the effects this
morning dehydrated for sure dry mouth
absolutely like sticky skin I have a
headache
you have a headache you tired you don't
have alcohol in your blood anymore that
food that we saw with though with the
breathalyzer test but what you do have
is something called acetaldehyde it
causes inflammation it gives your breath
that kind of smell that people get when
they're metabolizing alcohol and it's
one of the main reasons along with the
dehydration that you feel like they
right now we ran some tests but we also
my favorite the sort of motor skills
tests we test it's a hand-eye
coordination down perception one out of
ten three out of ten no I'm pretty sure
we can improve on that when we when we
introduce you to the cure today we have
coffee versus smoothie the fruit has a
lot of electrolytes and antioxidants
coconut water is great it has the same
five electrolytes as blood if you don't
have saline available to transfuse
someone you can put coconut water into
there there've aids and then you've got
you know the the ginger and the tumeric
which are actually anti-inflammatory
coffees like as old a cure as it gets
it's been in people's hangover regimen
for years and I also sometimes in their
sober you up regimen I feel like this is
gonna work let's introduce you guys to
the cure
here we have a nice big pot of coffee
and a specially crafted hangover
smoothie so let's let's triumph a night
of drinking on science for science for
science design for science how's that
tastes delicious how's the temperature
on the coffee just right
yes he will plate this morning with the
shakes yeah you withdrawing from a
depressant so your body is naturally
kind of swings the other way and it gets
agitated so you get that kind of shakes
and to you stun your liver with the
alcohol so it can't do one of its main
jobs which is to create glucose for your
body so your blood sugar crashes all
right we've tested the cure
we'll go test your vitals we'll see how
you guys are feeling feeling yeah but
most importantly tennis balls okay guys
you're about 120 over 80 folks still a
little bit best okay so let's get to the
tennis ball at the main event let's do
it so you know when you guys came in and
your baseline hangover you got one you
got three now we've done a cure of
coffee and hangover smoothie and we're
gonna see if you are able to harness the
power of those cures and have more focus
and better coordination and catch more
these balls
lovely all right first ball is loaded
I think everybody feels good right I
want to sit down and talk about this
okay let's do it all right I think I
think everyone should be very proud of
themselves you guys just look better I
think I definitely feel a little a
definitely a little bit better it's a
marked improvement about the headache
headaches gone I'm a little less
dehydrated it feels yeah I mean I could
still lay down that's for sure
yeah still looking forward to sleep and
feeling a lot better
guys look better we know coffee helps
with focus so you know and you seemed
more focused when you were there
absolutely I don't more focus and there
are a lot of other organic chemicals in
there and one of them in particular has
been shown to reduce liver inflammation
and another chemical in caffeine helps
decrease this this chemical in your
brain that causes the headaches and then
as far as the the smoothie coconut water
has the same five electrolytes that we
find in blood between that between the
antioxidants that help kind of catch up
all of the toxic free radicals that are
formed when you metabolize alcohol I
feel like this was a positive one thanks
for coming you guys I'm gonna have to go
and give coffee a solid be okay because
you know he felt better it is somewhat
hydrating
I mean caffeine doesn't necessarily mean
it's gonna dehydrate you and it does
improve your focus and your mood so okay
I'm going to give that the big and what
about the smoothie I'm given the
smoothie a b-plus okay because you know
it's scientifically it's a great
combination of things the smoothie has
electrolytes it's got antioxidants it's
got sugar which your liver needs
desperately because it can't make its
own at that moment I'm gonna give coffee
and a - because it just gets you through
the hours that you need to get through
or as I'm gonna give the smoothie the
b-plus coffee versus smoothie it looks
like you really can't go wrong I'm Fran
Kranz I'm dr. Keller wertham thanks for
visiting the GQ hangover lab I'll see
you next time
for more hangover cures subscribe to our
Channel and like us